I'm joined today by Ralph Wilson who is
director of research at uncock my campus
and this is something that we've talked
about to some degree Ralph but I want to
dig into with you and that is it really
goes beyond the Koch brothers but it's
sort of corporate influence and funding
within academia and at colleges and
universities so I guess for people who
maybe are not aware of what's going on
what what are you referring to when you
say unco k-- my campus sure well you're
right in saying that in corporate
influence is not a new phenomenon
but what we've seen as students and
faculty and community members through
our research is that the Charles Koch
foundation exhibits a very very unique
and precise amount of influence for
example through studying the contracts
that they sign with these universities
you know we're seeing them being granted
explicit control over all kinds of parts
of the program including the blanket
ability to just withdraw any part of
their funding there's sole discretion at
any time with as little as 15 days
notice in some cases so the amount of
control that that the cokes have is
exceptional and which is the reason why
we've sort of honed in on it but the the
issue of donor influence is one that
we're trying to tackle more broadly as
well let's maybe start with economics
departments what what is the influence
that this money from Koch Industries is
having on how economics is being taught
around the country well Koch Industries
is it's an incredibly large corporation
a very diverse with the cokes being one
of the wealthiest families in the world
they obviously have a huge stake in all
kinds of regulatory policy decisions and
so what's being taught in for example
economics departments is that
free-market capitalism is a moral
imperative that that government
intervention will always fail and
essentially that there is just one way
to look at the role of government in the
economy which is viewing it negatively
what about these sort of devils advocate
view which is
that listen if you look at economics
departments around the country there are
known conservative economics departments
there are other economics departments
like my undergraduate alma mater at the
University of Massachusetts where there
are alternative views that are more
prominently taught is it possible that
the Koch brothers are just giving money
to these schools that would be teaching
that stuff anyway and not really
changing the dialogue right well you
know just from the evidence that we've
seen we see clear clear examples of
donor influenced donors influencing the
creation of courses and majors and
minors hiring approving graduate fellows
so there's definitely a difference in
the kind of influence that we're seeing
but in terms of you know the the natural
diversity of of perspective on campuses
you know that is something that is
naturally regulated by by the peer
review process and by academia itself
and so the the sort of political makeup
of professors on campus is not something
that should be the business of one of
the wealthiest families in the country
it's something that should be left to
evolve on campuses by itself through
critical inquiry and not through this
constrained inquiry that we're seeing
what about outside of economics
departments I mean where else is this
money influencing academics well you
know this money is basically going to
any department where the donor can shape
how students think about the economy or
you know think about the impacts of
policy which is increasingly are many
many departments philosophy schools of
law schools of history you know the
revisionists project undertaken by
corporate funded free-market academics
is is one that really knows no bounds I
mean even English departments ways that
students view literature for example is
being impacted is this something that in
your sense the Koch brothers are sort of
specifically managing or directing or is
it sort of like hey
you you guys should look at putting
money here and there and it's gonna have
this general influence or that general
influence I mean do we know how involved
at the micro level the Koch brothers
actually are right well that's really
what makes our work sort of easy in one
sense is that everything that we're
doing you know we're not speculating and
we're not opposing the cokes money
because they say they have some
political opinion that we disagree with
we're working directly from documents
and recordings from inside the Koch
foundation itself that spell out they're
very explicit model so the Koch Network
not just the Koch foundation but the
wealthy donors that they orchestrate
they call the seminar Network they work
off of this very simple model that the
Koch foundation has developed and so you
it's three pieces of four converting
private money into policy change you
fund universities to produce
intellectual raw material and then
you've you fund a think-tank to refine
that raw material into policy points
into something useful
and then you fund politicians and
political front groups to lock all of
that into law and so from inception to
policy change we see that the cokes are
using a very clear top-down model and
they're sharing it with their donor
network so in a way it sounds like or or
I mean it seems abundantly clear that
the academic side of this is sort of
related to the I guess what we'd call
the the think-tank industrial complex or
something like that
absolutely the Koch the Koch officials
refer to the the their network of think
tanks and a network of academics as
fully integrated and so we're taking
their word for it and as we go through
these programs we're seeing left and
right that Koch pointed academics are
also just coke funded think tank
scholars as well in in large large part
what can be done about this in other
words at the individual school level the
schools become dependent on the money
and at the same time it seems that
making a sort of legal argument against
this is possible but not the easiest
thing to do so what can people do well
there's a lot that you can do again
everything comes down to research we you
know we're not shaking our fists at a
donor's politics you know what we're
doing is we are documenting specific
examples of donors having influence that
only faculty should have so fine
we're donors have created of course
finding examples where these programs
are created outside of University policy
which is increasingly easy to do when we
start looking at the policies that
campuses have and then sort of beyond
that research and exposure you know
we're pushing for transparency to get a
better understanding for example of
these contracts but also for
universities to strengthen their
policies that are is essentially
allowing rampant donor influence in the
first place would you be less concerned
about this money if it wasn't horrible
on 15 days notice because that really
seems to be a big aspect of how the
funding you know if you're gonna make
decisions based on having funding but
then that funding can be pulled with
with 15 days notice
you basically have no protection from
the the source of that funding saying I
don't like what you're doing is that
provision specifically a big part of the
problem it's a huge part of the problem
it's one that we constantly refer
faculty and students back to because
it's one of the more obvious examples of
strings attached to money they can
literally just with the back you know in
as little as two weeks but the contracts
are full of such what we call mechanisms
of control that is not the only
mechanism of contractual control and so
even if you remove that the donor still
retains tremendous influence over the
programs and much of the influence
frankly is set up after the contract is
put in place how you know graduate
fellowships are selected and distributed
things like that become much more
systemic and as co-funded officials and
Koch affiliated administrators
increasingly populate and grow these
programs those additional problems
compound what about the legal side of
this I mean are there any possible legal
it is anything illegal possibly
happening here well we've seen some
really great examples about a year ago
we published a book entirely on Florida
State University and the Charles Koch
Foundation and in it you know we've seen
examples where money that was supposed
to go to as a grant with with
deliverables so for example this is
money that would not be tax-deductible
there's academic goods and services it
was instead being funneled funneled
through the research
or through the to the university's
Foundation where gifts go which are
tax-deductible and we saw emails where
professors are hiding deliverables in
order to allow cokes money to be given
tax-deductible as opposed to through the
Research Foundation now there's a lot of
ikura even that sounds like that
wouldn't necessarily be the anything
that the Koch brothers are doing wrong
but that would be the university right
or am i misunderstanding well you know
this is just our example of being able
to see that close up you know one of the
things that we see as widely done is
that these multi-million dollar you know
donations that have these strings
attached with you know with deliverables
and the like are being Canada's gifts
you know there's a larger pattern here
but there's also just an abuse of the
distinction between gift versus grant
that you know we think is troubling from
a from a sort of an IRS perspective but
there's also just rampant corruption
conflicts of interests that have been
noted by faculty investigations there's
there's kind of a lot and the deeper we
the deeper we dig the dirtier the
operation appears to be how widespread
is this in terms of the types of schools
in other words is it more more happening
at large research institutions do you
see the influence at liberal arts
colleges there's a great mix you know
again Koch the cook family is one of the
wealthiest in the world they can afford
to diversify their strategy so we see
huge centers being built at state
institutions we're seeing increasing
programs being built up what they call
beachhead programs essentially on Ivy
League campuses or liberal arts colleges
that are historically known to be
liberal they're establishing small
programs to create a foothold of
legitimacy on some of these more
surprising campuses definitely but a mix
of private in public and you know
campuses from all over the states but
these campuses also sit in states where
their political operation can use them
strategically as well so that's a
considerate that's a consideration for
them to this really I mean for me this
relates a lot to this push that we've
seen from the American right to sort of
frame higher education as left-wing and
I mean not not only is there a
conversation to be had around that that
has nothing to do with this type of
funding but this is sort of a directly
opposing source like to whatever degree
you believe that that's the truth about
American higher education this is an
influence that's pulling academia very
much to the right isn't it
yeah and purposefully you know it in
documents we have a speech that Charles
Koch gave in in 1974 to the Institute
for Humane studies which is located at
George Mason University and in it he
recognizes both the threat that the
universities play to the free enterprise
system namely corporations under under
attack by by free inquiry and people who
were researching the effects of
capitalism but he also acknowledges the
the usefulness that universities play in
shaping public opinion and so he gives
the twofold approach of essentially
neutralizing the threat that
universities play casting them as these
as these leftt propaganda centers
because it's self-interested but then
also co-opting the sort of cultural
machinery that universities provide um
in shaping opinion and policy we've been
speaking with Ralph Wilson he's director
of research at on coke my campus very
very important work and I really
appreciate you sharing it with us yeah
thanks for having me